Das ist wirklich ein super spektakulärer
Plan der Europäischen Weltraumorganisation
(ESA): Bei der Mission “Comet Inceptor”
sollen drei Raumsonden einen Kometen abfangen,
der sich erstmalig auf dem Weg ins das innere
Sonnensystem macht.
Eine echte Premiere also, denn so könnte
zum ersten Mal ein Komet untersucht werden,
der von der Sonne noch völlig “unberührt”
ist.
Im Glücksfall könnte vielleicht sogar die
Analyse eines interstellaren Objekts gelingen!
What?
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
aktiviert die Glocke, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts.
Los geht‘s!
Herzlich willkommen!
Jetzt gibt es grünes Licht für diese neue,
wirklich spektakuläre Mission der Europäischen
Weltraumorganisation (ESA).
Hier ist der Name Programm.: “Comet Interceptor”
- übersetzt also so viel wie “Kometen-Abfänger”
besteht aus drei Raumsonde, die auf auf Abfang-Kurs
gehen.
Im Visier: Ein Objekt, das sich vorher noch
nie der Sonne angenähert hat.
Zusammen mit dem Weltraumteleskop “ARIEL”
sollen die Raumsonden 2028 ins All starten.
Dann werden sie quasi im Weltraum geparkt:
Aus Sicht der Sonne könnten sie dann “hinter
der Erde” auf ein passendes Zielobjekt lauern.
Dieser sogenannte “Lagrange-Punkt L” liegt
1,5 Millionen Kilometer “hinter der Erde”
- wie gesagt: von der Sonne aus gesehen.
Die drei Komponenten der Mission bestehen
aus den Sonden A, B1 und B2, die sich dann
laut Plan kurz vor der Ankunft voneinander
trennen und das Zielobjekt dann während des
Vorbeifluges aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln
analysieren.
Das hat den Vorteil, dass der Komet von mehreren
Punkten aus gleichzeitig beobachtet werden
kann.
Echte 3D-Informationen wären also das Ergebnis
und könnten zum Verständnis dazu beitragen,
welche Einfluss die Sonnenstrahlung auf Kometen
hat und wie er mit den ständig wechselnden
Sonnenwinden interagiert.
Alle drei Sonden sollen optimal ausgestattet
werden, sodass sie nicht nur in der Lage sind,
den Kometenkern zu messen, sondern auch seine
Staub-, Gas- und Plasma-Umgebung analysieren
können. 2028 wird die Mission ins All starten
und die Reise kann Monate oder sogar Jahre
dauern.
Schließlich ist nicht wirklich absehbar,
wann ein optimaler Kometen-Kandidat entdeckt
wird.
Heißt also im Klartext: “Comet Interceptor”
könnte eine ganze Zeit lang im All herumlungern.
Im Worst-Case vielleicht sogar so lange, dass
ihm die Energie ausgeht, bevor überhaupt
in Richtung eines Kometen gestartet wird.
Als Notfallplan hat die ESA allerdings bereits
Ersatz-Ziele ausgewählt: Kometen, die wir
bereits kennen.
Laut Plan der Weltraumagentur soll die Mission
fünf Jahre nach dem Start im Jahr 2028 abgeschlossen
sein.
150 Millionen Euro sind dafür eingeplant.
Doch der ganze Aufwand wird sich lohnen - da
sind sich die Fachleute einig.
Schließlich erlaubt diese Mission erstmalig,
ein “kosmisches Fossil” genauer zu analysieren.
Denn das Zielobjekt soll ja ein wirklich ursprünglicher
Komet sein, der unberührtes Material aufweist,
das vom Beginn des Sonnensystems stammt und
außerdem auch noch nicht durch die Einstrahlung
der Sonne verändert wurde.
Noch einmal anders gesagt: Das Zielobjekt
wird also eines sein, das zum allerersten
Mal aus den aller-äußersten Regionen des
Sonnensystems in die inneren Regionen kommt.
Solch ein Besucher kann beispielsweise ins
innere Sonnensystem gelangen, weil in den
äußeren Regionen des Sonnensystems zwei
Himmelskörper kollidieren und sich somit
ihre Bahn ändert.
Um dann in die Nähe der Erde zu kommen, brauchen
solche Besucher tausende Jahre.
Nach einer Runde um die Sonne dauert es wieder
tausende von Jahren, um zurück in ihre alte
ferne Heimat zu gelangen.
So lange wollen Forschungsteams natürlich
nicht warten!
Und da kommen wir schon zu dem riesigen Problem,
das Astronomie-Teams weltweit hatten: Die
Zeitspanne zwischen der Entdeckung eines solchen
- sogenannten langperiodischen - Kometen und
dessen Vorbeiflug an der Erde ist viel zu
kurz.
Jedenfalls reicht diese Zeit nicht aus, um
eine Raummission ins All zu planen, zu bauen
und zu starten.
Und genau deswegen ist das Konzept der neuen
ESA-Mission so erfolgsversprechend.
Die fertige Raumsonde wartet einfach im All,
bis irgendwann ein optimaler Kandidat vorbeikommt!
Dazu der ESA-Direktor für Wissenschaft - Günther
Hasinger: “Unberührte Kometen sind völlig
unbekannt und bieten ein hochinteressantes
Ziel für die Erforschung aus nächster Nähe,
um die Vielfalt und Entwicklung dieser Objekte
besser zu verstehen".
Durch die beiden vergangenen ESA-Missionen
“Giotto” und “Rosetta”, die ja auch
Kometen im All erforscht hatten, konnten bereits
wichtige Erkenntnisse gesammelt werden. 1985
war “Giotto” ins All gestartet, um den
“Halleyschen Kometen” zu erforschen. 2014
war “Rosetta” auf der Oberfläche des
Kometen Kometen “Tschurjumow-Gerassimenko”
gelandet.
Eine total aufregende Sache, denn dadurch
konnte nicht nur ein Komet aus nächster Nähe
beobachtet werden - wir sind sogar noch darauf
gelandet.
Doch der Unterschied zur neuen ESA-Mission
liegt auf der Hand: Sowohl “Tschurjumow-Gerassimenko”
als auch der “Halleysche Komet” waren
bereits durch den Einfluss der Sonne verändert
worden.
Doch der ESA reicht das alles noch lange nicht.
Zumindest der Besuch eines unberührten Kometen
sollte also auf jeden Fall drin sein.
Im besten Fall könnte sogar ein interstellares
Objekt als Zielobjekt dieser Mission dienen,
so die insgeheime Hoffnung der Weltraumorganisation.
Dazu Günther Hasinger: “Jetzt ist es an
der Zeit, einen unberührten Kometen zu besuchen
oder sich auf das nächste Oumuamua-ähnliche
interstellare Objekt vorzubereiten".
Oumuamua war im Herbst 2017 mit einem Teleskop
auf Hawaii aufgespürt worden - wir hatten
darüber ausführlich bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction berichtet.
Bei dem 400 bis 800 Meter lange Brocken handelt
es sich um das erste im Sonnensystem entdeckte
Objekt, das aus dem interstellaren Raum stammt.
Nach Meinung von Astronomie-Teams weltweit
wohl kein Einzelfall - und so besteht tatsächlich
die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die neue ESA-Mission
solch ein exotisches Objekt abfangen könnte.
Klar ist aber auch, dass diese Wahrscheinlichkeit
nicht besonders groß ist.
Die Jagd auf Oumuamua beginnt!
Mega Video von Neugierzone.
Anklicken, anschauen und abonnieren, den Hammer
Kanal Neugierzone!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!